-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy, Golden Globe,
and Tony-nominated actor.
You know from his work
on the award winning series,
"Fargo" and "Angels in America."
He stars in "The Conjuring
The Devil Made Me Do It,"
which is in theatres
and on HBO Max now.
Let's take a look.
-[ Screaming ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Growling ]
-[ Grunts ]
-[ Screaming ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Screaming continues ]
-Grab his arms.
Don't let go.
-[ Growling ]
-Save your servant.
We trust in you, my God.
-Please welcome back to th
show, Patrick Wilson.
[ Applause ]
Hi, buddy.
-Super funny.
-Welcome back. Thank you.
I love your my pillow guy.
-Oh, thank you.
A lot of work went into it
a lot of work.
Welcome!
It's so nice to have you here.
-Thanks, Seth.
Ah, it's good to be here.
-Now based on the clip,
this is a movie about bein
with your kids
during the pandemic, right
-It is, it is. That's exactly.
-[ Laughs ]
-"Conjuring: The Pandemic Made
Me Do It."
-This is -- it's very exciting
to have movies back in theaters.
-Yeah.
-But this particularly is
the kind of movie that I think
we most lost
the joy of being
around other people.
-It's so true.
I went to a couple screening
on opening weekend last Friday
and I sat in the theater,
and to hear the sound,
to hear the audience
screaming and crying
and doing all that they do
Not crying, I don't know
why I said crying.
Weeping, really.
It's a sad, sad tale.
-Do you -- are you a screame
in horror movies, historically
yourself?
-No.
I go the other way.
I'm the worst audience
'cause I just --
I get very stoic.
And, you know, if it's a frien
of mine's movie,
I'll kind of laugh.
Like, "Oh, good. You got me.
I'm the worst.
I'm terrible.
-I think -- no, I like --
I think that thing
of like laughter in a horror
movie is also a wonderful thing.
-That's true.
-When you laugh at
the appreciation of how much
you were just got.
-Yeah. Well, you know what's
also funny?
I feel like there's a --
there's a --
trying to create a great comed
and a great horror movie,
it's so technical,
it's so similar with just
being done in the editing room
and really understanding
tone and the edit.
-Yeah, and timing.
You're so right.
It is.
They are very similar.
Now, this is something that,
I mean, when you got involve
with the first "Conjuring," yo
could never have predicted
-[ Laughs ] No idea.
-I mean, it's so popular.
-I totally knew.
-You knew in the beginning
-Yeah, yeah.
-You basically went into
the audition and said pick m
and we're gonna make
a billion dollars.
-I did.
I did a song and dance.
It was wonderful audition.
No.
I thought if we got it right
we'd be back for one or two.
I did not see all the tentacles,
all the spinoffs.
-Yeah, because this is a
franchise in it's own right.
-It's gigantic.
We're the number one horro
franchise in history.
We're $1.8 or $1.9, it doesn't
matter, billion.
-Right.
-So it's crazy. It's crazy
It's good.
-And are they fun?
They must be fun to make.
-It's super fun. It is.
We have the best time.
Vera Farmiga and I, who I adore,
we have the best time doing it
So, that's a bonus.
-And do you -- have you,
the longer you do this, becaus
of course now it's stopped being
one film, do you and Vera,
do feel like
you know more about
the devil?
-Oh, yeah.
Oh no.
I'm convinced that I could giv
an exorcism.
-Really.
-Yeah.
And it's complete crap,
but I really feel like,
we both feel like
we have this authority,
based on nothing.
Just really based
on reading the lines.
But I feel like, I'm good.
Like, if you have a ghost
in your house, call me.
-I mean, I think celebrity
exorcisms, on it's own,
could just be a really big deal.
-You know, if it doesn't wor
out, that may be the way to go
-Another franchise,
a franchise
with tentacles as well.
-Oh-ho.
-"Aquaman." Look at that.
-Oh.
-I didn't even plan that.
-A little reference.
-I'm just very --
but you're doing that
this summer.
You're gonna --
-Yeah, yeah.
-And when we last saw
your character,
you were in water jail?
-In Atlantean jail, heading of
to Atlantean jail like one does.
-You can't, obviously,
no one lets you say
anything about these movies.
-I'm in jail.
-But how -- you're in jail
How much -- how much trainin
do you have to do,
and how much of it
is water based?
-[ Chuckles ] Interesting.
Everything is water based.
My paints.
No, I --a ton of training, yeah.
But I made a pact with mysel
cause that's who you
make pacts with.
-Yeah.
-Last time, you know,
four years ago, I had to gain,
I don't know, 15, 20 pounds.
And I was like, "I'm not going
through this again"
'cause it was just way
too much food.
So I've actually tried
to maintain
the weight and all that,
so this was much more --
This is so boring. [ Snoring ]
-Right, cause it's not just --
No, but like, I think
it's important to note.
It's not just, like,
gaining 15 pounds.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's like gaining
the hard 15 pounds.
-Yeah. No no, that's true.
That's true, 'cause
for "Watchman,"
when I did "Watchman."
I just ate like a madman.
-That's like one of the few...
I mean, when you think about it,
you played one of the few
super heroes ever where th
goal was to be a little pudgy.
-The goal was to be pudgy,
like trying to get
my stomach,
and trying to get a gut.
It's so lame, but it's true.
-Yeah.
Well, that's very nice
that you
at least made that deal with
yourself.
Your -- Obviously,
your kids are --
What are they? They're almost --
both teenagers.
-Yeah. 14 and 11, yeah.
-Okay, so I know that you ar
very musical with your siblings.
-Yes. Yes, yes.
-Are your kids?
Have you roped them into it?
-No.
They both are great
at their instruments.
They will not play together.
-No jam sessions?
-No. It's the worst.
It's really --
-Will they play with you?
-It makes me sad.
Not so much.
-Okay.
-They will when we have concerts
'cause they like getting u
in front of people.
-Gotcha. Well, you actually do
have a band.
-Yes, we do.
-The Van Wilson, is it?
-The Wilson Van.
We like to switch it around.
-The Wilson Van, gotcha.
-Yeah, It's the Wilson Van
-But it's a Van Halen cove
band?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-About half our set is old
Van Halen tunes,
and that's actually been
one of the frustrating,
you know, parts of the pandemic,
not being able to play,
you know, concerts.
So we'll schedule
another concert
after I shoot "Aquaman," so...
-And then also -- I mean,
is this something that whe
you grew up with your siblings
were you guys
always playing music together?
-We were.
My -- our middle brother
is Mark,
who's a TV anchor in St. Pet
in Tampa Bay.
He's just an unbelievable
guitarist,
and we all grew up,
me and my older brother Paul
and Mark, the three of us
always playing.
And it really, honestly,
when he turned 40,
now a long time ago, Mark,
cause you're old.
No, that's terrible.
When he turned 40, we said w
should get a big party togethe
and play cause we hadn't playe
together in years.
So what it became, honestly,
is this, you know,
annual event for to us
get together,
not around his birthday anymore,
but we have these concerts
It's all for charity
and we start a foundation,
the Wilson Family Foundation
so it goes to all these loca
charities down there,
and we just get to go have fun
-That's really awesome.
Yeah.